my talk of the table is Winston do okay
use my talk of the table why because
he's in an Epic movie franchise that you
already know Marvel's Black Panther
directed by Ryan coogler it's smash box
office records when it was released back
in 2018 the numbers were off the charts
the film grossed more than one billion
dollars one billion with a B that's the
most by any black filmmaker and it's the
14th highest grossing movie of all time
thank you very much now fans were
shocked by the sudden death of star
Chadwick Boseman that was in 2020 so you
know he played the Black Panther
t'challa King of the fictional African
nation of wakanda the sequel black
panther wakanda forever serves as a
moving tribute to the Beloved actor and
his character the early reviews call the
film one of Marvel's best Winston Duke
plays mbaka the Jabar the Jabari tribe
leader so in this clip he joins a fight
to defend wakanda from any invading Army
in the wake of Black Panther's death
ah yeah
before you do that
do you do that for real let's see
the camera guy yeah
first on CBS morning's Winston Duke as
you see is here Winston congratulations
can I just say I went to a private
screening and the moment you appeared on
the screen the audience went nuts
because you walked in and you're what
are you eating you're chomping on
something I'm chomping on a carrot yeah
yeah so it's like you you you started
with comedy right away it's like you
turned up the volume on on Comedy in
this movie well this movie is so much
yeah you know it's it's very heartfelt
we're dealing with the legacy of
Chadwick Boseman and the loss of
Chadwick and you know the the loss of
the character t'challa yeah so everyone
in the movie is dealing with that grief
and ambaku serves almost as that little
valve on the pressure cooker that lets
some of the steam out so gets everyone
to laugh a little bit by telling some of
the truths that other people aren't
ready to hear yeah like that
um and and that function is you know
it's it's incredible yeah and let's talk
about Chadwick because Angela Bassey did
an interview and she said you know
viewers will walk away feeling very
satisfied because Chadwick was always in
our hearts now before filming started
the cast together went to go to
Chadwick's resting place dress what did
you all do what when did you do that and
what did you do so we did that about the
Sunday before we started shooting and it
was just our chance to say goodbye
because it all happened so sudden yeah
when it all happened none of us knew he
was even sick so I mean I was driving
home from a store and my sister called
and just said are you sitting down are
you sitting
um she said Chadwick passed and I was
like chadra cool what yeah what do you
mean because the Chadwick I know is a
young healthy you know spry guy and and
that's what made it doubly shocking
because most of us did not know that he
was 100 so this gave us an opportunity
to say goodbye say our our our parting
words I love that the cast did it
together yes including the new
characters so you know as you know name
more of the Submariner is a big
character in this yeah yeah and by his
world of talukan and even the new actors
were invited and it served almost as a a
tribute of bonding for us to you know
start yeah the first black panther had a
celebratory nature too of course um
eye-opening educating
um giving people a peek into what black
excellence and opulence is you keep
using words like grief and loss
how difficult was it to do this project
with everybody's Hearts so heavy
uh it was incredibly difficult but what
came out of that was a community where
everyone understood what you were going
through so the thing about grief is that
it hits you in waves you know on any
given day for any given reason something
might trigger you right and any person
might be going through that so there was
a lot of you know unspoken understanding
yeah on that set where today Winston
might be grieving tomorrow it might be
Leticia and you know you'll just pick up
on that and say take your time that
empathy I got you I got you we're not in
a rush this movie is going to be made
yeah let's talk to you let's talk about
your journey as an actor Gail and I were
talking about this ahead and we were
shocked to learn that your first movie
role was in the original black panther I
did not know that yeah and then
Additionally you signed up for the
sequel even before you saw a script so
pretty good bet on yourself who turns
down black panther I know but did you
read the script and go this is really
good oh once I read the script it was
was one of the best scripts I'd ever
read first and then
you know it took you on this entire
Journey that you don't expect yeah you
don't see a lot of the twists and turns
coming and if I could say it to the
camera there's a lot of twists yes
do you find it hard not to spill the
beans because I get so worried I don't
want to accidentally spill anything I
want everybody to experience what I
experience there's a Mickey Mouse has a
little dot on my forehead at all
and now it was so great when we learned
that Rihanna was going to contribute to
the movie and it says that you're going
to be in her fashion show The Savage
yeah will you be wearing lingerie ah yes
I will be uh Savage
I did I signed up for that one that's
how we go there's certain things and
certain names you don't turn down you
know what the opportunity comes you know
so the legs will be out
ain't nobody man of that hey but did you
feel did you feel pressure this time
around because it was such it I was
reading that the first movie made over
200 million first weekend unheard of do
you all feel pressure it's an all black
cast which also adds to some of the
drama here not every sequel is good
that's right Tony you know so it is uh
the thing that I I believe we all were
coming off the heels of covid yeah so
everyone was dealing with real life yeah
real life was way more dramatic than
anything we could even think of so
walking into you know making a film felt
secondary then we'd also suffered the
loss yeah yes that again felt secondary
yeah and the first thing that I did was
to just detach myself from any
expectations of what this was going to
be because black panther one was so
special so it was this huge watershed
moment that gave people permission to
dream again of course right and see
themselves in the present yes um as as
great and beautiful and powerful and I
said it could never be that it could
never be that again because it could
never be the first time but it could be
special but it can be special and that's
exactly what it is expectations are high
and from what I'm hearing you guys one
of the best expectations thank you so
much Winston Duke black panther wakanda
forever hits theaters on November 11th
and tomorrow we will be joined by the
films director Ryan coogler all right
okay boobs in the house are you sick of
people going wakanda forever whenever
they see you I'm sick of The Barking
okay
restrooms dinner I'm like you just drop
off my spaghetti